sur les vaccins la preuve qui fonctionne
et les phase iii elles ont été faites
donc après vous dites oui c'est une a
même conditionnelle sénat mm qui arrive
au moment où les mêmes arrive
habituellement c'est à dire à la fin de
phase iii quand vous l'avez testé sur
soixante mille personnes dans une étude
après vous l'utilisez parce que sinon ça
sert à rien qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire d'autre qu'est ce que voulait
faire d'autre que des études sur trente
quarante mille personnes et une étude
qui a été faite aux états unis qui
montrent que ces vaccins protègent
extrêmement bien je suis encore plus de
personnes dans la vraie vie les vaccins
à rennes mais s'agit il marche quasiment
sur tous les variants on n'en sait rien
sur le variant brésilien parce qu'on n'a
pas fait des études encore mais on vient
de montrer qu'ils marchent sur le sud
africain
il marche très bien sur le britannique
qui contamine 85% des personnes
marie-france et après les histoires à
l'assemblée nationale petite question à
vous poser
marc khanne dernière partie mer ce
vendredi il faut s'inquiéter du variant
brésiliens ont pas hier on avait on
avait le docteur on avait lu didier
ludot rythme qui nous dit qu'il fallait
s'en inquiéter oui ce qui se passe au
brésil la seule information qu'on a sur
le brésil aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a des
enjeux qui sont réanimation c'est la
seule information qui nous arrive en
france près à quoi c'est dû
est-ce que c'est dû à une explosion
épidémique est un système de santé
défaillant et une population jeune qui
s'est totalement déconfit nez ou est-ce
que c'est du invariants tout d'un coup
qui est devenu extrêmement dangereux et
qui ne tuent que des jeunes je rappelle
qu'on avait dit la même chose sur le
variant britannique à l'époque tout le
monde avait dit qu'il était plus
dangereux
ça a été démenti récemment dans deux
études extrêmement solide aujourd'hui
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
qu'il n'est pas plus dangereux donc je
dis on a une flambée épidémique au
brésil on a des jeunes en réanimation
est ce que c'est à cause du variant
brésilien j'en sais rien probablement
pas c'est probablement plus la
population brésilienne qui s'est relâché
et a entraîné une flambée épidémique qui
a fait ressortir un variant à qui on
attribue la situation au brésil mais
monsieur des taureaux je pense qu'il a
pas du tout du tout du tout les preuves
pour avancer ce qui dit donc qui sème la
panique dans la population sans avoir
aucun élément et ça c'est pas bien parce
que ça crée beaucoup de torts et guillon
ne pensait qu'on nous prend pour des
cobayes oui bah c'est un secret pour
personne ces vaccins ils ont été conçus
en un temps record on sait qu'il ya des
normes sont vus financiers autour de ces
vaccins on a le sentiment en fait qu'on
préfère vendre des vaccins coûte que
coûte plutôt que
le temps de faire les études en bonne et
due forme est il tellement de polémique
dans le monde entier il ya eu des morts
il ya même eu des polémiques qui a
affirmé notamment pour astrazeneca et
une écoute qui a était mort suite à mes
gars des oiseaux bagués tony mais il a
des mains libres mais bien sûr avec la
pilule avec le doliprane avec tous avec
la moto avec la pilule est donc de ces
polémiques qui sous-entendait que les
tests pour astrazeneca n'avait pas été
fait en bonne et due forme donc oui je
comprends je dis pas que les vaccins
sont pas efficaces
je comprends que certaines personnes
aient le sentiment d'être pris pour des
cobayes celsa mais bien sûr qu'on ait
des cobayes dans la mesure où on ne
vient pas de nous dire qu'il faut aller
vite et et vous êtes totalement
contradictoire je vous tombe c'est vrai
relativement dangereuse parce qu'on
n'arrête pas et on en à faire une
situation totalement inhabituelle
donc bien sûr qu'il ya un risque bien
sûr que mais quand on est par ailleurs
on se plaint que les vaccins n'arrive
pas assez vite donc on est totalement
contradictoire tout le temps dont il
faut faire quelque chose
rendez compte qu alors que le président
de la république il y a un an annoncé
une pandémie mondiale
et là j'ai pas critiquer à ce moment là
le confinement strict généralisée parce
que la mortalité à la létalité aurait pu
être réellement équivalente à imola
c'est à dire très lourdes jusqu'à 30%
aujourd'hui on a ce recul suffisant qui
nous démontre que la létalité pour des
personnes infectées dont l'âge est
inférieur à 70 ans est très très faible
c'est du 0 5%
tant qu'on est en train de piquer en
augmentation en hier en pleine épidémie
alors bon moi je suis beaucoup plus âgée
que martin mais quand j'ai fait médecine
on nous apprend jamais il fallait
vacciner jamais il fallait vacciner en
pleine épidémie
là on vaccine à tour de bras et je
répète qu'il y à des traitements donc on
se trompe on fait prendre des risques
inconsidérés
j'ai bien être recul à moyen et à long
terme correct martin oui je suis assez
d'accord sur le côté cobac sont même
totalement d'accord moi je pense qu'on
teste sur nous je pense qu'on n'a pas
fini les études contrairement à ce que
dit nicolas et qu'on continue de tester
sur nous et je pense que les validations
pose question par exemple en europe les
validations celle agence européenne des
médicaments ya plein de polémiques
autour de cette agence on dit parfois
qu'elle est à l'as
solde des lobbys qu'elle est à la solde
de l'industrie pharmaceutique qui valide
qu'est ce que les validations sont
conformes moi je doute sur le hip hop
high madame je suis entièrement d'accord
le refoulement